question la première réponse c'est une
dar k alors là je vous le dis parce que
la première réponse c'est déjà une dar k
on n'aurait pas pu faire mieux comme
réponse là sur la première la réponse
est elle à gonfler les chiffres
elle a gonflé les chiffres ont fait un
tour de l'actu et donc je vous propose
les réponses vous me donnez les
questions elle a gonflé les chiffres
qu'elle à la question oui café isabelle
morini-bosc après un truc chiffres de
rte ou non mais c'est presque ça non
mais c'est sa console dit à moi c'est
une bassine et miloud de 0,1 dans big
man lundi dernière je me suis excusé sur
certaines questions isabelle gens me
parlent quelle excellente analyse a fait
isabelle morini-bosc les derniers au
sujet des audiences télévisuelles
non il faut me donner la chaîne à faut
me donner la chaîne est là isabelle
morini bosc a fait sa belle mort est
allé à kyle gla donc quand des audiences
d'une chaîne tingwick chili café café
vous venez de la pause et non la chaîne
retrouver la chaîne louis abbatiale non
non non non mais chelsea à six chaînes
de télé ou un café isabelle au sujet des
chiffres d'audience de gulli julie très
bonnes réponses
deux ans michel mr et oui là la bourde
d'isabelle la semaine dernière dans la
matinale d'yves calvi sur rtl isabelle
morini bosc est une spécialiste des
chiffres a fait une petite bourde en
annonçant que gulli donc chaîne du
groupe m6 puisque ça a été racheté par
m6 comme rtl ab réalisé un record
d'audience à 2 3 millions de
téléspectateurs ont regardé et je vais
vous donner la véritable audience de
bully juste après vous allez voir il ya
eu comme position derrière le polar de
la 3 6 millions 500 mille et laurent
gerra sur tf1 et bien du lit et ses
dragons sa section 2 millions 300 mille
téléspectateurs c'est clair si
l'historique non chasse et je pense que
c'est historique c'est historique alors
il sait story qu mais sauf que isa ma
chérie
dragons part de la dérive a réalisé deux
cent trente mille téléspectateurs et 1 %
de part de marché gulli était 18e chaîne
mais on embrasse les dragons et elle
s'est excusé après isabelle mais pour
vous dire voilà bravo isa parce que
j'avais une idée je me suis trompé dîner
alors curieusement oui jean-marc que
j'aime infiniment quelqu'un de son
équipe a fait rigoureusement les mêmes
blonde comme moi ce qui fait qu'en plus
on a cru que j'avais copié sur lui l
anglais les chiffres tous les jours et
que je me suis trompé tout seul j'ai
besoin de personne complet bravo semer
la bonne personne pour m'excuser mais
moi je vous ai fait un truc ce week end
pas du tout ma chez moi vous adore mais
attendez on peut 2 millions 3 même le
patron de guilad is your mais qu'est ce
que vous les effectifs et mais c'est
normal c'est pas écouté tous les
brestois mans c'est vrai elle aurait
fait la même bourde sur france inter au
loto le buzz que ça aurait fait
heureusement le ch'ti sur intel
heureusement